to be here but last minute CH change of
plans he's not going to be here uh let
me quickly tell you what we are doing uh
30 minutes I hope I can finish
everything we are going to talk about a
minut to one matching problem with
distributional constraints and uh there
are many applications of that and uh
many important applications for many
important applications stability is not
a policy requirement at all uh but uh
when you look at those papers
researchers usually impose stability and
uh they usually start like this they
they take a problem an application with
distribution objectives they assume a
choice function and presumably a
substitutable one impose stability and
they come up with the standard Solutions
and we we are going to claim that this
approach actually has its own
shortcomings and it's it call it may
lead to misleading conclusions in in
particular distribution objectives are
not necessarily compatible with the main
policy objectives and when you just
assume stability you bury the problem
one more layer deeper and that's what we
are going to do instead we are going to
begin with the policy requirements first
we are going to formulate them as axioms
and of course we are not the first one
to do that there's a long tradition of
axiomatic uh characterization in uh in
the literature without even imposing
stability and we we are going to
characterize a defer acceptance
algorithm with a particular choice
function of
course our outcome our solution is going
to be stable with respect to that
uh particular choice function but
eventually we are not going to be able
to meet all of our policy requirements
we are going to try to optim optimize on
that one that's where we are going to
differ from the rest of the literature
in the rest of the literature when the
even the recent ones they State uh
blocking conditions as aums and when you
uh when they eliminate those blocking
conditions they end up with the
stability condition again it is not in
that regard our work is going to be
quite different than what uh has been
done in the literature let me give you a
simple example think of this as a school
choice example there are three
applicants a low-income student a low
another low-income student and a high
income student and uh there's one School
uh there's a baseline priority L1 has
the highest priority than H then L2 and
school one the school wants to reserve
one seat for low income uh for a low
income student what does this mean
reserving a seat right that is how it is
usually done um we divide the school
into two sub schools one for lowincome
students where they are going to be
favored and this school is going to have
only one seat reserved for L uh income
students and um an open seat this is
also open every every seat in the resort
seat is also open as long as there's no
lowincome student who claims
that high income student can get it
right and after that
uh the low income sub school is going to
elevate the priority of low income
students without changing the Baseline
priority among them so all low income
students are going to be ranked higher
than high income the relative ranking is
not going to change and the open seat is
going to keep the Baseline priority
then there are the literature usually
studies various types of choice rules
one of them is applicants first apply to
the open seat in this case uh everybody
is gonna apply to SL L1 is going to get
the seat right then everybody else oh
sorry uh everybody's gonna apply to the
open seat first L1 is gonna get it L1 is
gone now the remaining students two and
H are going to apply to Res apply for
resolve seed two is L2 is going to get
it in this way both loow income students
are going to be assigned to school
alternatively applicants could first
apply for the reserved seats right in
this case L1 is going to get the resered
seat and open seat is going to go to H
so the choice of the choice rule has
distribution
implications now uh both actually you
know both H assignments are stable with
respect to the corresponding choice rle
right we have no problem with stability
here but the problem is stability is not
a PO policy objective in such
applications it is
actually if you look at the uh it is the
objective is actually minimizing
priority
violations and that is usually not
compatible with distribution
objectives if you put distribution
objectives on your menu to one matching
problem and if you have a baseline
priority ranking you are always going to
end up with some priority violation
right so stability is not a policy
objective but prior to violations are
the literature does not the lit ignores
that they mostly focus on uh this what
so-called precedence order or seed
processing order and they H study the
effect of different Choice rules on how
many lowincome students are assigned the
school for example that's the main
concern what we are going to do is
actually we are going to go back to the
Bas phics we are going to take an
axiomatic approach following a long
tradition and we are going to cre corize
uh uh uh the defer acceptance mechanism
with a specific Choice rule without even
imposing stability that's what we are
going to do uh priority based uh
assignment there are many applications
uh uh and there are also many
applications with diverse and
distribution objectives some of them
segregation policies in public schools
affirmative action in college admissions
and so on uh for example in Chicago
Chicago Public Schools The Selective
schools Chicago divides uh neighborhoods
into such four tis depending on
socioeconomic status and for each tier
each School reserves
17.5% of the
seats in in New York a big Chun of
schools actually reserve a big Chang of
seeds for low income uh uh students
these applications are everywhere uh
that there's of course a baseline prior
to ranking at each school for example
for the selective schools in Chicago
students take an exam and they exam
scores determine their priority ranking
that is the Baseline uh uh priority that
I am talking about and uh the common
solution is really a reserves rule uh
modify that they Reserve some seats for
the beneficiary groups and modify the
priorities at those seats for the
beneficiary group groups and choose a
choice function and apply find a stable
uh matching with with respect to the
choice function now uh our goal is we
are going to take an aomc approach and
we are gonna ask the following question
why reserves reserves rules we we are
not even going to start with reserves r
rules right we are going to start with
policy requirements we are going to
model them as axioms and they are going
to give us the reserves rules that's the
first thing we are going to do and this
is going to be a big class a big class
actually uh let me get back to this
point then the next question is which
Reserve rule again we are going to
impose further policy requirements and
we are going to show that the F
acceptance mechanism where all schools
use a particular Reserve rule which I'm
going to call a regular Reserve uh is
the unique mechanism satisfying our aums
and objectives that is the goal uh we
are not the first introducing objectives
there are in particular haalo I believe
hfalo is the first one who studied the
res we are not the first one who does an
axiomatic analysis of a single school
choice problem actually uh fedo and Bo
pioneered this work uh studying Choice
roles from an a point of view but uh we
are we can claim that we are going to be
one of the first to study this problem
in a general matching framework and I am
going to again I'm going to give you a
characterization of the defa acceptance
uh uh algorithm without imposing
stability now uh bunch of applications
with reserves in reserve rules in real
life and let me go back to the
literature and let me start where we see
the problem this is probably Comm sunas
is probably probably the most General
treatment of the problem Comm andas
assumes seed specific
priorities a school might have uh seats
for low-income students High income
students middle- income students and
each seat might actually each seat not
only types spe seats but each seat might
have specific priorities that their
objective is finding strategy proof and
stable mechanisms and presence order is
a major contribution of their work but
actually their precedence order excludes
Choice rules that I'm going to talk
about that minimize priority
violations and we see this as a
manifestation of lack of axiomatic
approach and uh uh followup work by
again t er uh dur at all andak at all
they also study uh the impact of
Preston's order on the distribution but
none of them pay attention to the
possibility of Baseline priority
violations which is going to be in
avoidable when you impose distributional
objectives in an otherwise standard many
to one matching problem now uh so let
let me skip this one uh what I'm going
to do is I'm going to do hopefully I'm
going to do two few things I'm going to
start with a decentralized school choice
problem that is super common charter
schools for example are entitled to run
their own Admissions and in mines
Charter Schools run their own admissions
in New York C prior to
2003 uh application process was
centralized but admissions were
decentralized each School were admitting
uh its own set of students so there's a
we are going to study that decentralized
problem this is going to boil down to a
single school's problem and in this
single School problem minimizing
priority violations is going to
characterize a choice rule which I'm
going to call a regular rule okay and
then I'm going to switch to the
centralized school choice where we are
going to have many schools many students
uh many two ones uh matching with
distributional
constraints and then minimizing priority
violations
again I'm not talking about stability
I'm trying to minimize blocking payers
and eventually I'm not going to be able
to eliminate all of The Blocking pays
but I am going to try to minimize the
number of blocking pays that's going to
yield a different acceptance with
regular Choice
RS why is this different this is
different because there are other
characterizations in the literature but
if you read them carefully their aims uh
State uh the blocking conditions as aims
and when you eliminate those blocking
conditions you end up with stability and
no surprise if the resulting uh choice
is substitutable and if you if you want
to uh optimal and everything you end up
with a different acceptance with that
substitutable choice function this one
let
me introduce some uh notation we are
going to have a set of applicants each
set of applicant is going to have have a
type loow income student High income
student uh student so on uh I'm going to
this is the set of type T students in a
low income students is going to be a
subscript law and uh there's going to be
a baseline priority over all applicants
and uh we are also going to have some
type specific reses this is the number
of seats that a school wants to Res
for low-income students and number of
seats that it wants to reserve for high
income students and so on this cannot
sum up to a number more than the
capacity we can also have
kotas kotas turns out to be very easy to
handle kot has actually bound the number
of certain types admitted I'm going to
skip that one in this talk I'm going to
focus on the difficult part the resoures
part and uh we are in for the
decentralized uh school choice we are
interested in the choice function a set
of students are applying to a school and
the school is going to choose from that
set without exceeding its
capacity number of seats and
uh here are the reserves rules I'm not
going to start with this one I'm going
to arrive to that rule but let me first
clarify what it means I am going to
divide the school into t plus one sub
schools one for open seats and one for
each type each type of school is going
to have exactly the reserves as number
of seats and the remaining seats are
going to go to the open seats and each
uh Reserve school is going to modify the
priority ranking by elevating the
priority of type T students in the
Baseline priority and the op
uh otherwise the its ranking is going to
be consistent with the Baseline priority
and the open seats are going to use the
Baseline
priority now uh here is a piece one more
piece of uh
notation we are going to consider some
uh application orders this is an
application order for applicant a
when the set of applicants is given by
capital A so this application order may
depend on the applicant and it may also
depend on who else is applying what does
this mean this means uh this is going to
tell us in which order of type specific
seats we are going to consider that
application
applicant right in other words is the
applicant going to apply for a loow
income seat or for a high income seat or
for a open seat first
and what is next that is the application
order and uh by you actually by dividing
this school into t+1 sub schools and by
endowing each each applicant with an
application order we are turning a
single School problem into a into one
matching problem right this this is
playing the role of
preferences now I can find a choice
outcome I can apply the defer acceptance
to this problem
where each school has a
capacity each school has a priority
ranking and each has a preference over
those sub uh sub schools and that's what
I'm going to do I am going to create a a
choice function associated with an
application order by using the standard
student proposing different acceptance
algorithm now
uh examples of this is again
uh uh in the L it's examples about uh
now let me stop a bit here let's forget
about the reserve rules let us go back
to the policies what are the
policies the first one is what do we
mean by
reserves the first axium all the way
goes all the way back to earlier work uh
which we are going to call Reserve
respecting it says the
following this is the number of seats
reserved for type T
students if there are not that many type
T applicants select all of
them if there are more
than that many typy students select at
least that many type students this
indicates that this actually already
says that let's first try to assign as
many type teach stents as possible to
those resources that is our first aim
that's what what we mean by reserving a
seed the second axiim is kind of an
efficiency axum it's going to be what's
called non bful as long as there are
seeds they're going to assign all of the
applicants if number of applicants is
less
than uh
the capacity we are going to assign all
of them again I am ignoring uh the kotas
it's so easy to uh uh modify this with
kotas now here is my uh main uh
objective this is the typical blocking
condition in a typical uh uh stability
notion I'm going to say that an
applicant a is going to violate the
priority of applicant a prime if a is
chosen a prime is not chosen but a prime
actually has a higher Baseline priority
right is ranked higher he's not chosen
but another low ranked uh uh one is
uh uh chosen we want to eliminate
priority violations to the extent
possible when we eliminate all of them
we end up with the standard typical
notion of
stability but sometimes we are not going
to be able to eliminate all of them we
are going to allow some priority
violations but the certain priority
violations are not allowed one of them
is for example within type priority
compatibility if two students are of the
same type they cannot violate each
other's
priority that is the first one two low
income students there's no reason for
one of them to eliminate the priority of
the other
one that is the condition we are going
to impose on our allocation the second
one is we are going to allow some uh for
some priority violations but we should
be able to explain that why our reserves
policy then this is uh the
uh number of type T
students who are chosen by this choice
zle but they actually cause a priority
violation that number cannot exit the
number of seats reserved for that type
what does this mean this means if there
are five seats available for low income
five seats reserved for low income
students there might five priority
violations by low-income students
probably because they got into those
Reser seats not because they have high
priority but because these seats are
reserved for them okay thank you so the
first theorem this actually these four
aums characterize the reserves rules
that I gave you and these reserves are
this a pretty big class of reserves
rules application order can be student
specific it can actually depend depend
also depend on the set of applicants
right if you go back to uh commas and
sunmas uh commas and sunmas in in their
work application order or precedence
order is the same for all
students in this case it may actually be
different for each student and that's
going to be
important now
uh let me skip this one uh I'm going to
call a specific uh application order the
regular and it's this one each applicant
is going to be considered at seeds zert
for his or her type first if I am a low-
income student I'm going to apply for a
low income for a seat that is reserved
for low income seats first then I can
apply to any other for any other seat
doesn't matter if it's is a high income
or open seat if you are a high income
student you are going to apply for a
high income for a seed result for high
income first then you can apply to any
one of them
and actually it doesn't matter the rest
doesn't matter as long as each student
applies first to the seat reserve for
his or her her own own type the rest of
the application order does not matter it
always produces the same outcome okay
now uh back to the example again
remember this uh two low income one high
income one uh in this one uh uh the
first one applicant were applying to the
open seat first to low income students
are
selected uh in the second one uh each uh
type is applying to the seat reserv for
the type first here one low one high
right but no look at that the in
regular the top rank two students are
getting the seats in the other one uh
two low inome students are getting the
seats at the expense of violating AG's
priority so the regular rule rule does
not create any priority violations in
this particular example but the other
one does this actually is turns out to
be a general result among all Choice
rules that are uh satisfying are four
aums uh the uh one that minimizes the
number of applicants whose priorities
are violated is the regular rules and
that one for example is not included in
uh uh commas and typhoons work and all
the followup work right now
yeah
confus
that that as long as the application
order
GRS you
first yeah it says as long as as long as
you apply for your own each applicant as
long as each applicant applies for their
own type specific seat first the rest
doesn't
matter so consider uh two consider two
uh application orders all types apply
for their types first then for the open
seat let consider low high and open seat
right everybody I am a low income I
apply for low income seats first then
open seats then High another alternative
is I apply for low first then High then
open the remaining does not
matter yeah
yeah yeah I have to quick
so uh we actually there are other
alternative ways of modeling priority
violations uh the regular rules satisfy
those two uh but the question is do we
really need alternative rules right for
example if you go back to uh dur at all
where they talk about the WorkOne uh uh
uh the works on policies of Boston they
consider alternative Choice rules well
here's one the actually there's a point
there given a type T consider an
application order in which type te
applicants apply for the open seat
first and all other applicants apply for
their own Resort seats first that is
actually the best one for type T
students that selects the biggest number
of uh type T students among all the uh
uh among all the uh uh Choice Reserve
rules we characterized but do we need
that the next theor says we don't why
because we can always replicate whatever
we optain here or whatever we optain
with an alternative function by properly
setting the reserves and applying the
regular rule what does this mean this
means once we do that we can actually
explain any remaining priority violation
via our Reserve
policies that is not true with the
alternative uh
Solutions and uh so
uh to summarize uh Reserve regular
results can replicate any other Reserve
Rule and unlike uh ad hoc rules any
priority violation with regular reserves
is fully explained by the policy
therefore it actually provides a full
transparency in policy design
now what I'm gonna do next actually I am
not sure if I have time but let me first
have let me first summarize uh I'm going
to generalize the aims for assignments
that was for a assign to a single school
I'm going to consider assigning students
to multiple schools once I do that I'm
going to uh talk about uh minimizing
priority
violations when I do priority violations
in terms of set inclusion which means a
choice rule is going to have less
priority violations in terms of set
inclusions than another one whenever we
compare those two Choice rules over
different problems one is uh if there's
a priority violation in one of them that
prior to violation is going to exist in
the other one too in that sense it is
set inclusion and we do that defer
acceptance with regular Choice rules is
going to minimize priority violations
again I'm not talking about stability
here right there's no stability notion
here but turns out if you want to
minimize priority violations it is the
Deferred acceptance with regular
choice this is actually the first of its
kind actually to characterize a default
acceptance algorithm this way if you try
to minimize prior to violations in other
ways for example let us try to minimize
the number of priority violations that
turns out to be a difficult problem to
solve in particular MP heart and uh in
simulations we also we also compare
different acceptance with regular Choice
rules uh with Alternatives and we obtain
significant reduction in priority
violations with regular Choice rules so
what do I do H typical uh matching
problem uh
uh I'm going to say that
uh an assignment is let me at least one
of them an assignment is reserves
respecting if for any applicant and any
school as long as there is demand for
that school right as long as applicant a
prefers s to new a that means he or
she's not getting it then it must be the
case that there are not enough Reserve
seeds for that person that's how we
generalize Reserve
seats policies right um nonm fullness
again as long as there is enough seats
if there's somebody demanding it we are
going to give that seat to that
person and
uh a priority violation again a typical
uh blocking pair a a prime
s
uh a prime is assigned s with a lower
priority while a prefers s to
a that s to his uh
uh uh assignment now uh again the we
didn't type uh the other aums let me
actually talk about this I'm going to
say a assignment new Prime priority
violations dominates another
assignment here's how I'm going to
Define now how I'm going to think about
minimizing priority violations if the
set of priority violation instances the
blocking PES let us call The Blocking
PES under mu Prime is a subset of The
Blocking PES under
mu
this this one generates a smaller set of
blocking PS if this holds I'm going to
say new Prime par mu and I'm going to
try to minimize that
set not the number of priority
violations but I'm going to try to
minimize that set and when I do that the
outcome of Def acceptance with regular
Reserve rules is the
violations minimal in the class of
assignments that satisfy our other
acts
uh am I running out of time one and a
half minutes okay so let me just give
you the uh the a major uh uh School
District we have the test scores and
everything we divide the uh population
into low achieving and high achieving
according to their GPA and we reserve
seats uh 20% of seats uh for low income
St and 20% of seats for high high
achieving seats and low achieving seats
each we run the regular rule regular def
acceptance and the def acceptance with
the alternative rule the regular one
with 20% result for each type creates on
average
25 uh blocking PS uh the other the
alternative one actually
creates one five times more uh blocking
PS and this is consistent uh across here
let me just quickly
thank and
[Applause]
[Music]
finish go
ahead can you expend this kind results
if you have uh overlapping types and not
really that that would be very
challenging because of the compliment
issue there are things you can do you
can Define the overlapping types as a
separate type and impose reserves for
them but that would be a not so fancy
trick
right so not all priority
violation if you're in New York
City further
priority it's probably less serious from
a
policy for
instance viability priority for under
represented minorities so would that
change do you have any idea
what if you took preferences for policy
makers that have this kind of my my bi
answer would be no we can solve this
problem too and hopefully we can if we
can Define geographical uh we can define
a distribution constraints on
geographical distribution for example we
can Define uh catchment areas for each
schools that's that might be very
important for elementary schools and uh
we can actually reserve seats in the
catchment area and everything would
follow right away yeah but I meant there
a
trade
violations I think let me borrow one
more I think the uh benefit of this
approach is uh there's of course a
trade-off but whenever you violate some
priorities you can explain it under
these rules and then it comes to the
question of how should we set the
reserves I think that's a more
transparent question a pol a more
transparent policy question to have than
playing with the uh president orders to
favor some of the beneficiaries
thank
you thank you
again okay so I think